all right welcome to another edition of
beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
comer and today we'll be talking about
comebacks all right it's never good to
resign in a game of chess all right if
you resign it's over right so there's an
old phrase never give up never surrender
let's stick to that okay all right so
here we go I have the black pieces in
this position from a long time ago
playing a little kid named David Scott
all right here we go
so c5 he protects this is a good way to
get get d4 players out of book just play
C 5 they don't know what to do unless
they're good then they'll play d5 and
crush you but if they don't play d5 you
got them right where you want them
because because you get you got the C
file open life is good all right well
we'll take it first all right
so g6 Knight f3 Bishop g7 attacks so he
protects but remember that box is in his
Bishop
everything's protecting d4
all right don't worry about d4 it's a
pretty standard opening all right so
bishop pins the knight now so anybody
halfway good would just play Bishop to
b7 Bishop the d7 b7 break the pin and
unfortunately black plays Queen to c7
and gets himself in a lot of trouble huh
so white obviously the the Queen was
protecting the pond so white takes the
pawn attacking the Queen again so now
Queen to d6 there's anybody have any
good ideas all right so Queen is
attacking the knight here
okay should we take the night no we do
not capture pin pieces good so what are
some ways to to protect the night you
think II for strong alright but that's
okay we're not worried about d4 there's
more important things so II 4v4 should
be played in this position
unfortunately white plays Queen to b3
but it does protect the night and you're
still up the point so you're doing okay
so Bishop e6 now we got the knight into
a pin
alright so Bishop takes boo but now he's
got counter play so what do you think he
does now Queen to b7
uh-oh so White's queen is way down in my
territory and it's gonna be a lot of
trouble he's threatening Queen takes a a
check
he's also threatening night here bad
check for me for black so so black is in
a lot of trouble here so he decides hey
I'll attack not good not good so yeah as
Claudio yells out knight to c7 check it
breaks the connection between the Queen
and the rook obviously I'm not gonna
play Queen takes Knight so it might be
the best move but for that not very good
well I'd rather lose a rule than lose a
queen for a night so somebody from the
audience this ain't somebody unknown who
that's some random person it's same
black should play Queen King to d7 take
now what do you want and then just take
the night right what I'm gonna get the
night one way or the other so yeah you
should always be as protective
productive with your moves as possible
here so Queen takes check King to d8 was
played so check King here actually
actually black with the bishop here or I
did and now he gets another pawn yeah
alright so now we have our position here
white is clearly crushing black if you
count up the material you always want to
count up the material on the board 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 so white has seven ponds Knight
and Bishop are each worth a three apiece
let's add that up to 13 plus the Brooks
so how much does that add up to anybody
paying attention how much I think 23
let's say so White has 23 points black
has 1 2 3 4 5 10 yeah well we each have
9 billion points that's how much a king
is worth for you everybody filing at
home King is one 9 because if you lose
the King you're out of here so a lot of
people say he's got no value you
couldn't be further wrong ok
further from the truth thank you so okay
so in actuality white is up four points
but he's got a lot of things going for
him he's got this past a pawn and he's
just he's got a rook for a bishop pretty
good pretty good pretty good so would
anybody consider resigning in this
position the answer is don't even think
about it just just try to get some kind
of play here okay
so white plays Knight to e5
should we take no but you could give
them double punch so so that's what
black play No
in actuality you would not want to when
you're down material do not trade
material all right so it's a little did
I know it at the time f6 was the worst
move you could ever play in your life so
so I was thinking hey it was played in
1997 before Julian was born yes f6 so
take and now I got my night out so
things are doing okay so [ __ ] up the d2
where do you think he's going c3 pinning
alright so if you're black you want to
get yourself out of the pen so there you
go 84 but now you force me back so now
white is filing the pedigree to it to a
tee if you're up material train material
so now I got my pawns all connected
again so I'm doing alright so white
castles big mistake big mistake
if you're in an endgame and the Queen's
are off the board
don't be castling never castle play King
e2 you get checked and then you go King
III
and then you'll be fine well well King
you too King you choose played obviously
Bishop to a6 will be played and then
obviously at this IVs so sorry
so castling not advisable in an end game
alright f5 try to break open the castle
back when this game was played both
players are around 1200 at the time but
two of the best players in in the state
though yes yes so a 1200 back in 1997
was like an 1800 today so so so all
right so pawn takes rook takes all right
so would anybody think about playing c5
here to get the discovered attack it's
not even worth it so rook to d8 so now
he's in this castle and we still have a
potential for the back row checkmate
all we have to do is distract this rook
from the first ranking we got ourselves
a checkmate uh-huh alright but but we
got to just make it happen but I don't
know if it's gonna happen so check so
black would not want to trade rooks in
this position King to b6 rook takes pawn
so rook to d2 alright so interesting so
he just attacked black just attacked the
pawn what do you do here you could play
rook to b1 which is played but it's a
little too passive I would have probably
just played what h3 okay so so so h3
could be good but why not h4 because
don't you thing you're going to Queen
this guy all
have to do is get rid of this Jeep on so
just go for it h4 as fast as you can
yeah so so white could just play rook
here take but the thing is you now you
give him a little bit of hope with this
with the C pawn pass C pawn so he plays
work to be one Bishop a6 yeah route to
d3 so who thinks blacks should play
Bishop here now now your hope you got to
be tricky so the last thing you want to
do you would love it if you would take
this pawn so something you would not
want to do is play here because when it
takes if he does that it'll be check and
then your plan is ruined
alright so you want to make a move that
keeps the position exactly the same okay
Bishop the c-4 attacks the pawn he
attacks the bishop and the bishop a sex
perfect all right got right where I want
him now so if he takes here uh-oh the
bishop fork okay so I'm playing at 1200
so a4 so he doesn't fall for the trap
whether it's real learned brother it's
real learned that he does not fall for
the trip rook to a2 there's H for work
here all right so now the trap the traps
done so now it's time to protect it okay
but now he's got a lot of pawns coming
over here so we attack them
so lots of checks lots of checks so now
black is in some trouble
yeah even more than it was before yes so
rook here is threatening checkmate and
my bishop so things are looking pretty
dire for black but we don't even think
about resigning here okay we just want
to try try to live on as long as we can
so does anybody see how he can King to
b8 that stops mate so now the mate
thread is back on rook here still mate
so blacks got to play there okay so so
what white should do here is pretty
obvious actually he should play check
anyway Bishop gets pinned and then BOOM
the double attack attacked the pin piece
rook here and then yeah you could just
consolidate the victory or there's no
reason to you could just play a six as
long as you're not going to get
checkmated everything will be okay and
now black black has no good moves here
all right but luckily my opponent did
not see that great variation and he
decided to check me with b6 you want to
check horizontally with the rooks that
way it forces your competitors back
vertically doesn't really you just play
a little dance it doesn't really do much
all right so he's threatening checkmate
again so I just go back okay
no problem g4 big mistake big mistake g4
so take
rook takes and now he put his rooks like
this not good and there's no checkmate
anymore they're blocking each other yeah
yeah it's a Bishop f3 now I got a little
mate going if yeah if he plays rook to
g3 I'm in business and then the easy
checkmate
but you got to go all the way no
stopping short here all right all right
so rook to f6 he plays the move almost
as bad as rook to g3 rook to f6
threatening threatening the bishop and
checkmate again but unfortunately I do
have this happening now and now you see
the skewer and now black is right back
in the game so he's down so if your kid
would score at home who do you thinks
gonna win this game black or white or
draw so so a lot of people are thinking
White's gonna win but not me I'm playing
black I'm like oh I got this I got him
right where I want them
comeback kid here all right so let's see
how you can pull this out attack the
pawn he protects check yeah just keep
keeping active rook and good things can
happen
all right so so Rick just took the pawn
and now he threatens checkmate all right
so there's only one way to stop it
there Rick b7 check so there's a lot of
good ways for him to win here but
there's unfortunately a really bad move
y can make in this position what is the
worst move white could possibly besides
rook to b8 check a7 it happened
so take so so this should be a draw
still but white is kind of flustered now
he just lost his rook he's lost two of
his pawns he's about to lose another
pawn so so far so good he's he needs to
can you need to get a draw so King e6
all right here we go all right so so
King you the e7 looks pretty good but he
kind of wants to attack my rock over
here so once you get your so now once
they get the King on the Queen Square
he's got no hope and it's over yep
so that that's the game yep so the the
rains are the players at the time we're
about twelve hundred and twenty alright
so in this game I'm playing somebody a
little bit better than a 1200 it's right
at about eighteen nineteen hundred okay
yes yes and I have the the white pieces
here okay so II 4 E 5 9 up three attacks
the pawn Knight to c6 all pretty
standard Bishop c4 I am the big f7
square here Bishop to c5 castles always
Castle as soon as you can d6 d3 pretty
symmetrical fish up the g4 pins my
knight pretty annoying h3 attack ik go
away and unfortunately I think I see a
tactic here that I really do not I think
I see Bishop takes check King takes
Knight there check where they could
actually just oh yeah he could do a lot
of things here cook like getting to g6
could take but unfortunately this was
just hope and hope does not work in
chess so unfortunately it's got even
better you can just take with the bishop
take back with the bishop so so it's
moved six seven eight whatever and I'm
already down a piece for our point so
what should you do here should go out on
an attack okay you're losing you just
want to keep it going alright so now you
can't castle so we need a pawn storm
here so so naturally move our King away
to start the pawn storm alright so black
has a manually castled here so he's
feeling pretty good
so if he can withstand my pawn storm
he'll be able to win the game
the night threatening check it is
protected by the Queen so got to move
our King again here to stop it
pawn takes pawn takes rook to d8 guesses
rook on an open file so all his pieces
are pretty active mine or not all right
well things are looking alright things
are looking alright Queen to e2 so
that's that's a move because it's
threatening Shak
alright so so black has a couple
different ways he can stop this
you could simply play King h8 you could
play Bishop to b6 alright he could
overload his Queen Queen to f7 so the
queen is now stopping the check and
protecting the night alright it's
probably easier just to play King h8 and
just be done with the checks hey Knight
to c3 Knight the deep for Queen GG -
alright so now it looks like I'm back in
the game he played Knight to f4 and he's
like oh man I just lost the pawn so
obviously I can't wait to take can't
take so if your opponent does something
kind of silly like gives you a pawn
should probably really look and see like
why did he do that but I'm like oh yeah
back in it and so now everybody at home
can you see a good move for black that
corresponds with rook takes f4 yes see
how all these guys are on dark squares
here and he's got a dark square bishop
boom alright so the rook is in a pin so
this is the way the game is playing so
rook to f1 so should should black take
this rook
and there's no reason to it's in a pen
it's gonna stay there so so just keep
keep this uh your control happening okay
so okay so now it forces white to move
his king out of the pen
so now take take all right rook over all
right Knight to d5 so now we got some
threats happening here well yeah so so
if you were playing at home as black
even though you're 1900
you'd be like oh he's just plays Knight
they're no threat so he thinks I'm
attacking this pawn but I'm also
threatening check alright so I forked
the king and the Queen Oh interesting
so a very easy way to stop all this
shenanigans is Queen to d1 check very
good so I have like a playbook what
about work to f1
now Knight to f6 check with my pawn or
with the rook alright the pawn check
bummer
then I cry and it's all over no I will
not resign in that position but my hope
would be fleeting when I would try to
make the best of it alright so so that
would be a good way to stop the
shenanigans
so Knight to f6 check so rook takes f6
by okay
but luckily he decides I'm gonna take it
with the pawn three night so check game
over
alright so so when you're up material
you got to be thinking hey my opponents
gonna be doing some mad counter play
here alright so just watch out for the
checks and try to check them yourself
maybe like a our good friend Julian
suggested let's get it going alright so
are we ready for one more game alright
so this is this last game will be how to
play when you have a crushing advantage
okay so I showed you how how not to play
but this will be how to play when you're
just crushing I will be manually putting
these uh these moves in alright welcome
Lisa Lee hello
alright so white was our hero today
against a much lower rated player
alright so start at a 45 9 f3 d6 this is
called the Philidor not recommended
alright this bishops got nothing to do
Knight f6 Knight to g5 everybody's
hitting the f7 square here and I take c4
Knight takes and so this is a so now
he's threatening checkmate alright so we
don't want to take the rook and we don't
even want to castle we'll just play
Queen f3 Queen takes pawn takes Knight
to g5 alright big decision do I want a
free night or do I want a free book yeah
I'll take the I'll take the night
because I don't want my my night to get
trapped by g6 Bishop g7 makes sense then
you'll play g6 here alright
so free night h6 I'll go back work h7
now Bishop the d3 excellent finish up
the d3 Jesus wreck the g7 now can you
see a really cool move yeah yeah so
night to wear check alright but you
can't say double check so if you're
gonna double check always double check
because then the King has to move now
Bishop f5 check very good I was like
okay okay Bishop takes b7 rook to e8
all right so we remember when you're up
material just trade material it's not
very difficult and now I just need to
get my pieces off the back row and
everything will be good d3 a discovered
attack Bishop takes pawn do you think he
sees it very good
you guys have been paying attention it
takes a rook the Chi to Bishop III
Bishop takes pawn takes rook takes c2
night to a3 no it's okay it's all good
counter play he thinks he's getting her
getting stuff all right so it's okay so
you want to stop counter play all right
you can force a trade of rooks right now
rook the be one bolt rook the g8 all
right so now white now yet so now he he
doesn't want a repeat of all that junk
all right
so he plays King to f2 stopping the rook
King to b6
night a3 probably King to c6 Knight to
c4 King to d5 and now it's Kane well I
can't really do nothing right his rook
has no checks all right yeah so it's
real easy h4 and what can he do
and then it's just like he doesn't
really want to lose this pawn so he just
he just gives it up yeah
so so you just limit the counter play
and it was just be an easy victory yeah
yeah cuz I it was a comeback kid this
guy wasn't a comeback kid at not at all
not at all so so that's what you do